sir alex ferguson managed ryan giggs for
years and today came to his defense in
court good news alex
sir alex now 80 told the jury he'd known
mr giggs as a 13 year old school boy he
said he was a quiet boy who quickly drew
huge media attention after being
compared to legendary footballer george
best in the years that he managed the
midfielder sir alex told the court that
mr giggs was never aggressive and never
lost his temper
i would use ryan as an example in the
dressing room he told the jury and said
he would get the sharp end of my tongue
i knew he was strong enough to take it
he had a fantastic temperament without
doubt the best example we had at the
club
over the past two weeks the jury here at
manchester crown court have heard in
detail about the relationship between mr
giggs and his former girlfriend kate
greville who accuses him of assault and
coercive control today the court was
read out a letter written by ms greville
on the 29th of october 2020. that's just
three days before she claims that the
former footballer had butted her she
intended to send the letter to mr giggs
and called it the final goodbye
in the letter she called mr giggs a
compulsive liar and serial cheat and
listed several women with whom she
alleges mr giggs was having affairs at
the same time she says he was telling
her she was the love of his life
i fell in love with a person who didn't
fully exist she wrote i have no fight
left in me
earlier this week mr giggs told the
court he was a love cheat and flirt by
nature but he denies all charges against
him of assault and coercive control his
trial continues catherine of autopsy sky
news in manchester